Know you think I got a few you know like sixty four of you know so that could be very trying things that have not yet.
Race. Yes. Right. The story was very big because there was just very very. Well. Serious fish but it was just.
Yes You know when you come back and have another more interesting. Yes. Just because you're absolutely right.
Was very critical. You got to remember people really really came back to life.
Well this is where you see all the new money on your side. All right let's review.
One another source for the uses and you know pretty good. You know if you have a life written.
There's a guy called John Paul two He wrote a book called and I because you know you.
Live in the city you will publish in sixty one. Why not here and it was great for you. Well it's actually.
I mean your son was out of a need of you.
The other night and I said What do you mean you don't rise but God like you know we could go very slow.
What is it called The Cross right across the line.
So I went to the library the next time because it was really being borrowed from you know.
If there was a opening of a book which will obviously Fishel I read from you.
So I got it out there it's really wonderful because it just has so much. I mean you wonderful.
I mean it talks about being dragged bowled over having me up here writing coffee shop at the cross right.
It's just which is you know just such a tool but once again.
The guy is very discreet about sexual things so you really have to be really between because once again I mean he just
hard up with all the Broncos forty one year which was interesting to me to go from what I was told that he.
Yes I think. You know just the first British life that. So why. It's so easy to side with the money very. Well.
It was a lot more fun to have come across a couple given everything on the head to find just one of the I don't like to
raise the quality of play again. If you remember that day.
Can you remember much in my life and this was at five which was just yet. Shall I say.
We did this from some living room. It's not just the writers it was a great place to live through.
Well the floor here is your life your life. This is here we know they're here to be fifty fifty.
If you have a lot of this life that I just got to get the money that is what it means is that they are not really free
that you are now. OK size. I would like you to saw it was just yesterday just mission. There was a little that's. Here.
The function. Really there there. Oh sure yes. Get across the line. Yeah right. Lol. Well you know. I've. That's their.
I didn't really mean.
You know because there's no there's no I just was there was some story
and it was actually set up in the context of the fifty's and.
Yes he was very very logical when you see how you might have to be here right now
but you know the real issue with delight is the activities that the lazy. Yes really.